support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy okay so in this video we're gonna
talk about temperature and heat what is
temperature temperature is a measure of
how hot or cold something is especially
relative to something else how does that
relate to heat heat is actually the
energy it's the energy that flows
between things that are at different
temperatures specifically from the thing
with the higher temperature the thing
that's hotter to the thing that to the
thing with the lower temperature right
the thing that's colder now I want you
to consider something real quick imagine
a large pot of boiling water and a small
pot of boiling water temp water boils
assuming we're at standard pressure
which is one atmosphere water boils at
100 degrees Celsius so if this water is
boiling in this water is boiling they're
both at 100 degrees Celsius there at the
same temperature so we see here we see
here that despite the fact that this is
a small pot this is a large pot they are
both at the same temperature so despite
their different amounts they the same
temperature so what that means is that
temperature is an intensive property
which is something we talked about in
the previous video it's a property that
is independent of the amount of
substance however the large pot of
boiling water versus a small pot of
boiling water the large pot has more of
this water at that temperature and here
we have a smaller pot we have a less
water at that temperature so over here
we have in the hot in the large pot we
have a higher amount of heat energy
it took more energy to get this water to
this temperature here there's less heat
energy there's still heat energy of
course just less but that basically I
said that because I wanted to mention
that energy is an extensive property
it's something that does depend on the
amount of substance you have ok that's
all I want to say now about those two
things just cuz we're talking about the
basics on to something else that's
definitely definitely important is the
three temperature scales that are used
and they are degrees Celsius Kelvin and
degrees Fahrenheit notice that there is
the little degree symbol for Celsius and
for Fahrenheit but there isn't one for
Kelvin we don't say degrees Kelvin we
just say kelvin so we don't say if
something is at 400 degrees four hundred
Kelvin we say four hundred Kelvin not
400 degrees Kelvin so one thing I will
mention is that Fahrenheit is pretty
much used in the US and a few other
countries but overall not that many
countries use it and in science it's
pretty useless unless like the only time
we ever really talk about it is if we're
taking a temperature from Fahrenheit and
trying to convert it into these other
two scales so Fahrenheit is pretty wack
anyway so Celsius is used pretty often
actually and it's based on the the
freezing point and the boiling point
which I'll abbreviate as FP and BP for
now the freezing point and boiling point
of water at one atmospheric pressure
okay so so that's Celsius there Kelvin
is actually called the the absolute
scale talk about why in just a second
it's called the absolute scale and it's
kind of the science go to right it's
like V it's the SI unit of for
temperature and so most of the time I
mean when possible like
so impossible a lot of the times calvin
is used and it's it's really the go-to
when it comes to using a temperature
scale in science now back to Celsius
here in Celsius the freezing point for
water we're talking about water here the
freezing point for water and degrees
Celsius is 0 so 0 degrees Celsius is the
freezing point of water the boiling
point is at 100 degrees Celsius the
freezing point and boiling point of
water and Kelvin are the freezing point
is 273.15 Kelvin and the boiling point
is 370 3.15 Kelvin okay for Fahrenheit
the freezing point is 32 degrees
Fahrenheit and the boiling point is 212
degrees Fahrenheit again not too
important there I mean it's important to
know but it's not used very often now
note something that you might notice is
that the freezing point and boiling
point of water and Celsius are a hundred
units different and they're in Kelvin
it's the same thing it's also 100 units
different so what's important to notice
there is that they have the same degree
like that each degree or unit is the
same oops the same magnitude is the same
magnitude or size each degree size or
each unit size is one 101-100 of the
difference between the freezing point
and boiling point of water v so so one
unit change in degree Celsius is equal
to one unit change in Kelvin as far as
the difference right the magnitude of
the difference but from one unit to the
next is the same but they differ in in
what they do they differ in their zero
okay what's zero me in each case zero
degrees Celsius is defined as the
freezing point of water
zero Kelvin however is not not the same
thing zero Kelvin is is absolute zero
absolute zero and what that is that is
the lowest temperature that is
theoretically possible theoretically
possible that's an important idea there
because this means that that zero Kelvin
if is the lowest possible you know
temperature that means that all Kelvin
values are positive of course 0 is just
0 but that means you can't have negative
Kelvin degrees you can have negative
degrees Celsius okay now one thing
that's really really important when it
comes to these three temperature scales
being able to convert from one
temperature scale to another so I here
I've drawn or I've written down some
formulas the first one here relates the
temperature T sub K that's the
temperature in Kelvin and T sub degrees
Celsius so this one's solved for
temperature in Kelvin which means that
if you want to find the temperature in
Kelvin and you know the temperature in
degrees Celsius you just take the
temperature in degrees Celsius and add
273.15 now if the opposite is true and
you have the temperature in Kelvin and
you want to convert a temperature in
degrees Celsius you would just solve for
T sub degrees Celsius and without to
subtract 270 3.15 from both sides and
you get the temperature in degrees
Celsius is equal to the temperature in
Kelvin minus 273 point 15 now what if
you have Fahrenheit going on so if
you're the temp if you want to find the
temperature in degrees Fahrenheit you
would have to take nine fifths the
temperature in degrees Celsius and add
32 to get that temperature and if you
wanted to find the temperature in
degrees Celsius you would just solve
this equation for T sub C so we subtract
32 so you have T sub degrees F minus 32
and then multiply that by five nights
multiply both sides by 5 9's which would
give you this
now so these are four different
equations if you I mean if you think
about that way but I wouldn't think
about it that way what i would do is i
would just memorize this one and this
one and then manipulate them if need be
to these other two right if you ever
need them so if you know these two then
you should be able to convert any
temperature from any temperature scale
to any other hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful be sure to video with the
like and don't forget to subscribe if
you haven't already also be sure to
share the video with anyone you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying